so the cdc issued new guidelines today
in a 60-page report on how to safely
reopen schools in restaurants and
trap mass transit it also included a
warning that some institutions should
stay closed for now
for example it is also calling for
sneeze guards on the school buses and in
class lunches rather than in cafeterias
and it also says after we have all been
wiping down our groceries leaving stuff
outside
that in this new report they found that
the virus quote
does not spread easily from touching
surfaces
or objects so here now to help us sort
this out is dr richard besser
former acting cdc director under
president obama and president of the
robert wood johnson foundation
he is also on new jersey governor phil
murphy's reopening
team dr buster thank you very much for
being with us tonight good to have you
thank you thank you martha it's great to
be here
so what do you think about that it is
interesting because we were told
originally there's
all these scary stories about how it
hangs in the air for 24 hours
and then if it lands on metal it's there
for 48 to 72
hours or on packages um that was really
you know a bit of the of the early panic
in all of this why would that change
yeah you know this is one of the reasons
why it would be so
valuable to hear from cdc scientists
every day you know early on when it when
a
new infectious agent appears what what
we don't know
far exceeds what we do know so there's
work that's done in laboratories so
work in a laboratory may say well we
found in the laboratory this survives
for a certain number of hours on
different types of surfaces and
we can find it in the air what you then
need to do is say okay
let's look in the community at what are
the what are the important ways this
is spreading and that's where you can
see yeah well in the laboratory you
found that
but we found in the community that it's
really being close to somebody
uh who who's sick within within six feet
that's the important thing and those
other
other ways are not so important
yeah um it basically says that you know
between people who are in close contact
within six feet
uh through respiratory droplets coughing
sneezing all the ways that we
you know sort of would anticipate in a
normal situation but this is
you know much more contagious so why is
it do you think so much more contagious
or
is it given what we're learning now well
you know there's still a lot of
unanswered questions in
in terms of that when when i compared to
something like
the flu the flu we know spreads really
easy between children children get sick
they spread it to each other they bring
it home
one of the unanswered questions here is
is how important are children in disease
transmission and that's critically
important because
we all want to get our kids back to
school this fall and
if we can understand how do we do that
in a safe way you know as a
as a parent as a pediatrician i want to
know that
the safeguards are in place to limit the
risk as much as possible we can't
eliminate it
but can we drive it down so that people
are comfortable getting their their
children back to school
yeah let's hope um one of the things
that has taken on a lot of significance
is getting everything reopened and as i
mentioned you're on governor murphy's
reopen
team and i've spoken to a lot of doctors
who say look
we need to go back to school we need to
go back to work
this is from a group of 600 doctors who
wrote a letter
to the president urging the end of the
shutdown they say the millions of
casualties of a continued shutdown will
be hiding in plain sight
but they will be called alcoholism
homelessness
suicide heart attack stroke or kidney
failure in youths it will be called
financial instability unemployment
despair
drug addiction unplanned pregnancies
poverty
and abuse what do you say to that doctor
those are all
important things and and yes people have
to get back to work
but one of the concerns i have is if if
public health is put up as
as the enemy of the economy restarting
instead of
as the road map you know we want workers
to get back to work but it should be
done in a way that they feel
safe and comfortable that all the
protections are in place and we want
people to go back to businesses
but they have to feel comfortable that
going into a store or a restaurant
won't put them at increased risk so you
know data
understanding where this is transmitting
and where it's not
places where it's going down
significantly and they have the capacity
to
to test people and to figure out who
they've had contact with
and make sure that those people are in a
safe place so that they
don't spread it to others then yeah
those are the measures and so
seeing this this this guidance from cdc
will give a lot of
valuable information to to businesses to
schools
to consumers so they understand how to
do this in a safe way
well a lot of people in new york and new
jersey who are desperate to get back to
work
um to feed their families and to get
back to their lives so
um hopefully the the you know council
that you are on in new jersey will
help us get to that goal as soon as
possible doctor thank you very much
good to have you here tonight